mathieu kassovitz pourquoi vous avez
décidé de vous vous rendre en ukraine à
la map parce que j'ai la chance d'être
ami avec jr et que jr a été invité par
les ukrainiens lee moore est demandé de
venir exprimer son art chez eux car ils
ont besoin d'être d'être entendus et
cette couverture est le résultat de sa
donc exactement vous avez inauguré avec
lui ne voit la une ferait sans cesse
avec avec jr et donc vous avez décidé de
partir avec lui il m'a dit on par là bas
je débranche est-ce que je peux venir
pour port film et on a filmé exactement
les voilà alors au départ vous y alliez
bon bien sûr vous saviez que vous alliez
voir certainement l'horreur de la guerre
mais je pense que vous avez vu des
choses incroyables vous êtes vous même
un enfant de réfugiés
mathieu kassovitz est important pour
vous dia lire non mais je sais moi je
suis hongrois enfin moulage parti
hongrois partis français c'est c'est la
même chose c'est mon pays c'est les lots
j'ai été éduqué dans l'europe de l'est
beaucoup j'allais tout le temps là bas
donc je connais la mentalité g et puis
j'ai eu la chance de travailler aussi
sur le bureau des légendes et de tourner
à kiev pendant plusieurs mois on a
rencontré vraiment les gens donc quand
c'est quand cette histoire est arrivée
j'ai repris contact avec les amis qu'on
avait là bas et puis on essaie de
s'intégrer là on pensait juste à les
faire se cet événement et repartir moi
j'étais juste venu en assistant et le
proxy qu'on a vraiment découvert parce
que le livre est une ville qui n'est pas
encore en guerre fin et que jusqu'à ce
matin puisque l'on parle de bombarder la
nous quand on y était elle a été
bombardée juste à côté le jour d'avant
les avaient bombardé des centres
militaires d'entraînement donc c'était
très précis c'était pas encore on se
sent donc pas en danger la ville est une
ville qui est comme paris vit
normalement
avec des gens qui ont une partie de leur
famille qui est peut-être en danger de
l'autre côté donc il ya une certaine
tension mais mais mais malgré tout
l'énergie est très haute tous les gens
sont venus ont participé avec nous pour
cette photo et quand on est reparti là
on a pris la dimension du problème parce
qu'on est tombé sur
des kilomètres de réfugiés pour arriver
à une frontière où tu as juste deux
policiers qui font le contrôle de tous
les passeports d'une manière très
stricte pour être sûr qu'il n'y ait pas
de trafic de problèmes et de et puis il
ya des drames humains tout le temps
parce que c'est des familles qui se
séparent les pères doivent rester parce
que jusqu'à 60 ans et doivent ils
doivent être réservées être capable et
surtout ils veulent et puis des familles
qui ne veulent pas partir donc ils sont
il ne fut pas l'actrice d'ukraine ils
fuyaient la guerre dont et quand on est
arrivé à ce poste on a réussi à passer
devant si on a réussi à passer de
contraire se vante tout le monde il y
avait je vous dis de kilomètres de queue
sur 5 mètres de large que des femmes et
des enfants 50 % d'enfants aucun cri
aucun problème pas du tout de gens qui
essaient de passer devant la queue ou
quoi que ce soit à côté tard et que pour
les voitures c'est 25 heures de
d'attentât il ya des gens qui
abandonnent leur voiture
les gens devraient attendre le soir je
sais pas comment ils fonctionnent parce
que j'allais signer sur la la la tente
que ça devait créer malgré tout ils
disent que c'est entre 15 heures
d'attenté dans le froid on passe une
nuit les gens arrivent de l'autre côté
fatigué mais toujours avec une certaine
énergie et les gens qui les réceptionne
de l'autre côté en fait sont des
bénévoles qui comme beaucoup de nous on
regardait ces images et sons dit il faut
que je fasse quelque chose ils ont
rempli leur voiture ils sont partis là
bas en s'attendant à pouvoir amener du
matériel à des gens qu'il ya des
organisations déjà présentes et pouvoir
offrir leur aide et en fait quand ils
sont arrivés s'est rendu compte que
c'était eux l'organisation et donc ils
ont commencé à s'organiser autour de ce
camp il y avait personne et en deux
semaines ils ont monté un campement
maintenant il ya beaucoup de de street
food pour que les gens soient réchauffer
arrive yade et une bonne organisation
malgré tout ce ne sont pas les grosses
ong ce sont des toutes petites ong ou
des gens qui veulent ce qu'ils veulent
participer d'une manière ou d'une autre
et donc nous ce qu'on est en train de
faire je suis rentré de paris je le dis
ce qu'il faut qu'on essaie de faire
c'est de coordonner les gens qui veulent
aider et les demandes et les besoins qui
sont sur place voilà parce que c'est
vraiment un truc de citoyen à citoyen et
c'est un truc et on a rencontré des
français absolument incroyable donc
l'iran qui est qui va être maintenant
assez connu avec son chapeau de pirate
qui l'utilisent pour jouer avec les
enfants parce que pirate et un mois
international et que les enfants aiment
ça et que ils ont des sacs de petits
trucs de plastique où il attend les
mauvais il m'a dit viens avec moi on va
je vais te montrer pourquoi on est là
ils ont pris leur truc qu'on allait
donner au monde et leveaux missouri quoi
et c'est aussi simple que ça ils sont là
en transit entre deux trois heures et le
simple fait de sortir d'un pays en crise
et d'être accueilli de l'autre côté cela
change énormément de choses ça permet la
fluidité aussi des flux de la delà de la
communication de du transport et tout ça
et ces gens là commencent à être
fatigués dons nous je suis venu là pour
vous montrer sur leur site ils ont créé
une page facebook sur c'est pour ça
qu'on vous aime et qu'elle vous pouvez
regarder et alors qu'on voie de la
solidarité collègues de produits de
première nécessité pour les familles les
enfants voilà on vous allez tout l'est
et vous pouvez scanner voilà et c'est
très important valeureux mec tu as mon
ballon mais lors de l'émission et on va
le remettre d'ailleurs toutes là toute
la semaine prochaine et laissé jusqu'au
apprécié c'est lilian qui est donc le
pirate qui a qui est un chef
d'entreprise qui a une tête bien faite
et qui a proposé que on organise les
élans de solidarité région par région
donc sur ce site vous allez avoir les
informations qui correspondent à votre
région vous allez vous mettre sur des
tchats sur what's app et on demande
aussi aux préfectures de chaque région
de rentrer sur c'est sur ces sites parce
qu'ils vont avoir des gens qui vont
ramener des réfugiés sur des enfants il
faut que ce soit contrôlée il faut être
sûr que tout se passe bien il faut que
les préfectures soient au point mathieu
kassovitz aujourd'hui vous avez vous
êtes allez vous sur le terrain vous
trouvez qu'on sait que c'est quoi le
message sur la communauté internationale
la france notamment est ce qu'on fait
assez pour l'ukraine ou bien où on va à
chaque fois que les gens qui viennent on
a eu deux militaires la semaine dernière
nous on dit rien n'arrive en fait voilà
on le voit on voit rien arriver on va en
parler avec le président d'unicef-france
dans un instant mais c'est le sentiment
que vous avez eu aussi écouté je peux
pas dire ça parce que j'ai pas envie
d'être négatif et devant le dans lequel
ce qui se passe je pense que ce qui est
important c'est que c'était des gens
comme ceux qu'on a rencontrés là et que
ces gens là sont assez
intelligents et volontaires pour ce pour
mettre leur égo de côté et s'organiser
d'une manière complètement autonome le
problème qu'ils ont c'est qu'ils sont en
train de faire quelque chose qui est
considéré qui peut être considéré par
les polonais comme illégal on peut pas
arriver dans un endroit à côté de la
frontière et dire on installe un camp
n'importe comment donc il faut que les
grosses ong s'installe pour pouvoir
légiférer un petit peu tout ça et
organiser tout ça le problème c'est que
les grosses ong mettent du temps parce
que c'est des grosses machines mais
aussi parce que le pays est un pays
souverain la pologne est un pays
souverain et ne veut pas et c'est un
pays riche dans lequel unicef n'a pas
vraiment de raison d'être comme en
france ils sont plutôt dans l'est dans
les pays en difficulté ou l'est où ils
sont vraiment en demande et ce n'est pas
ça fait pas partie forcément de leur
mission donc nous c'est à nous de
remplir cette mission de recevoir ces
moments là c'est pas du tout il n'y a
rien d'autre
au moment de l'entrée de citoyens et on
s'est rendu compte en faisant en
revenant au temps des médias que ça crée
beaucoup de demandes il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont envie qu'ils ont une
semaine a passé qui ont du matériel est
donné qu'ils ont un camion a pas donné
et donc ça ils vont essayer de faire
avec ligne ans avec ces gens là un truc
vraiment très simple il n'y a pas de
budget pour ça on n'a pas de deux en a
pas on n'a pas tout ça donc c'est juste
du whatsapp et de l'organisation
citoyenne